my dear
brother the advice I give to myself and
to all my brothers and sisters is to
leave
this uh
evil uh for indeed Allah
said indeed we have advised those who
came before
you from from the people of the
book and we advise you with the TAA of
Allah we advise with the tawa of Allah
and tawa is to make a barrier between
you and the
Haram so that you don't fall into the
Haram you make a barrier and the Halal
is clear and the Haram is clear and
these are the from the Haram
matters would you like that for your
mother to see them naked and your sister
and your wife and your CH and your
daughters and your aunts no you would
not like that so why would you want to
look at other people's mothers and
sisters and aunts and daughters in such
a derogatory
manner may Allah protect
us these are from the lments ofan from
the plots of
Shan and don't follow the footsteps of
Shan he's a clear
enemy Shan is a clear enemy
so take him as an enemy don't take Shan
as a friend or someone
to to
follow for indeed he will take you
slowly slowly alluring you to the
Haram to the greater Haram starting with
the Haram and then the greater Haram
first the look then the touch and then
the Haram then the the greater Haram I
mean the Zena and Allah says don't come
close to
Z because if you come close to it you
will end up falling into it so guard
your gaze keep away from these filthy
acts of
looking at naked
pictures keep away from that which will
harm you it's a
disease it's a disease that will harm
you slowly slowly you go astray guidance
will be taken out from your heart and
you will go towards slowly slowly until
you cannot recognize truth from
falsehood so leave these lowly
ways and hold on to the de of Allah subh
be upon
uprightness for Allah subh tala is
testing Us in this life to see those who
do righteous actions from those who do
evil acts this is a test it's only a few
days
patience it's like a few dreams as IM
said it's like a few
dreams so go past this world quickly and
safely for indeed the true better life
lies ahead of it and Allah said
that the hair after is better and
everlasting and better so why fall into
these
sins and lose
your if you end up slowly slowly going
astray
and you never know you may end up even
denying Islam in the end because sins
start small and then they become bigger
and bigger
as said sin start as a hands spand and
an arms length than a mile and you never
know before it's too late you end up not
being blessed with
guidance and not being blessed with Russ
with the which is Enlightenment to doing
good and in the end you lose it you lose
everything
they lose themselves and their families
on the day of judgment and that is the
great
loss remember their Hellfire whenever
you are about to do a
sin and look into these evil
pictures alluring you to forbidden
actions remember the
Hellfire and remember the punishment of
the grave remember Allah subhana T's
punishment don't look at how
small a sin may be but look
to to the one who's Allah abbar the
greatest come to Allah and seek
forgiveness and come to Allah with a
pure
heart come to Allah by lowering your
gaze by keeping away from these evil
Acts whoever guards between his Jaws
meaning his tongue and he guards that
which is between his legs meaning his
private parts I guarantee him Paradise
the said so keep away from these lowly
Paths of pornography of these evil
acts and don't come come close to the
Haram because you'll end up falling into
it and then and then what is then you
become engrossed in sins and desires
as for the one who feared the meeting
with his Lord and he kept away from his
desires his lowly desires then Jah will
be his abod get married if this becomes
a disease for you get married and keep
away from these evil
things keep away remember that meeting
with
Allah how will you be if these are your
actions how will you
be so humble yourself here before you
are humbled there humble yourself here
in this life with obedience to Allah and
keeping away from Disobedience before
you are humbled and your sight is
humbled in the because you're going to
come to
Allah and you're going Allah will come
to
you Allah will come to you and he will
question you or he will present you your
actions so come to Allah with a pure
heart come to Allah how your actions how
you want your actions to be may Allah
forgive us our shortcomings